[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le
mercredi 14 février tout de suite les
titres de cette édition c'est une voie à
contre-courant dans la mobilisation pour
la ligne 18 4 maires des communes de
l'essonne et des yvelines dont magny les
hameaux et donner une conférence de
presse aujourd'hui avec des associations
ils réclament une autre desserte du
plateau de saclay est là où est prévu un
passage du métro en aérien sur un
tronçon de 13 km ça ne vous a pas
échappé aujourd'hui c'est la saint
valentin certains la fête d'autres noms
des villes comme elle en courante en
tout cas donner les moyens aux amoureux
de faire leur déclaration des messages
affichés sur les panneaux lumineux et en
ce jour de saint-valentin justement il
devait rouvrir au public le parc
zoologique de thoiry débutera sa saison
ce samedi finalement à cause de la météo
cette année les visiteurs pourront
découvrir un nouveau pensionnaire le
jeune rhinocéros unesco deux invités à
suivre aussi dans ce journal franck le
ton responsable de la communauté emmaüs
de trappes qui reprend son activité et
invite également de ce journal anna
cabri président de l'agencé des espaces
verts d'île de france elle vient nous
parler des arbres remarquables rester
avec nous pour en savoir plus son
calendrier n est pas encore fixée mais
le projet lui établit la ligne 18 du
grand paris express permettra de relier
à terme l'aéroport d'orly à versailles
35 km de métro qui passeront notamment
en aérien par le plateau de saclay un
tronçon qui inquiète certains élus et
associations impact environnemental
économique ou encore agricole leurs
préoccupations sont nombreuses les
détails avec ce reportage de nicolas
kirillovitch c'est un peu le combat de
david contre goliath
quatre communes et huit associations du
plateau de saclay opposé ensemble à un
projet de plusieurs milliards d'euros
porté par l'état et les principaux élus
du territoire
un combat qu'il mène principalement
depuis la déclaration d'utilité publique
de la ligne 18 il y a un an lorsque l'on
regarde donc à un public qui a été menée
dans le détail on s'aperçoit très bien
qu'il ya toute une partie de l'enquêté
publique qui a été de l'avis des gens
qui ont été quand on était auditionné
qui a été écartée ou interprétés c'est
là où on s'aperçoit que la société du
grand paris a essayé de masquer
la vie des des gens pour faire passer
son projet trop cher trop dangereuses
pour l'environnement est inefficace pour
répondre aux besoins du plateau de
saclay élus et associations locaux ont
déposé en tout deux recours devant le
conseil d'état
leurs espoirs se faire entendre sur
leurs propositions
tous les alternatives qu'ils auraient pu
l'être notamment des transports
innovants sous forme de petits véhicules
ou des téléphériques etc tous ces
projets là ils ont été étouffés ils ont
été tués dans l'oeuf
on a tous privilégié sur la ligne 18
personnes ne connaît véritablement le
dossier technique
or nous ce dossier technique nous
l'avons largement étudiés et nous savons
qu'il ya des possibilités autres qui
coûterait beaucoup moins cher et qui
serait beaucoup plus facile à mettre en
oeuvre des idées et des projets que les
élus du plateau de saclay pourront
présenter lors d'un rendez vous à
matignon le 22 mars prochain
c'est en mars aussi que le gouvernement
doit enfin annoncé le nouveau calendrier
de grand paris express transport
toujours attention si vous empruntez
régulièrement les lignes n uds et le rer
c à partir de ce soir 22 heures un
mouvement social des aiguilleurs de
trappes et versailles impact tout le
réseau sur les trois lignes prévoir 1
train sur 2 pour connaître l'horaire de
votre train avant de vous rendre en gare
rendez vous sur le site transilien.com
alors pourquoi les cheminots à se
mobilise-t-il demain réponses collectées
par nicolas kirilow liszt réagir une
situation qui devient explosive
c'est à dire l'augmentation des cadences
avec l'augmentation de la circulation
des trains depuis plusieurs années en
parallèle de sa une multiplication des
travaux à effectuer sur le réseau ile de
france pour rattraper le sous
investissement chronique de ces trente
dernières années
c'est qui débouche sur l'augmentation
considérable de la charge de travail
notamment en ce qui concerne la
possibilité d'effectuer des travaux et
pour toutes ces raisons il se met donc
en grève pour revendiquer d'une part les
embauches et les renforts en personnel
nécessaire pour effectuer les travaux
cette situation n'est pas acceptable
donc ils revendiquent aussi le déblocage
des salaires il n'y a pas de raison qui
est ou qui augmente sauf les salaires
elle rappelle donc des as ce soir 22h en
répercussion d'un mouvement social local
un train sur deux prévu sur les lignes c
n ai eu l les perturbations sont à
prévoir jusqu'à vendredi
8 heures du matin restez informés sur
transilien.com elle était en sommeil
depuis juin 2016 la communauté emmaüs de
trappes reprend ses activités réception
de dons à nouveau à partir de demain
l'ouverture au public se fera elle le 3
mars
bonsoir franck le ton vous souvenez vous
êtes le responsable de la communauté
emmaüs de trappes une communauté
présente depuis 1989 dans la ville
pas d'activité attrape pendant près d'un
an et demi elle manquait à la ville
cette communauté oui oui tous les
messages que l'on a depuis qu'on a
annoncé notre notre arrivée prochaine
effectivement nous montre quelques
allemands qui est indifférent niveau
donc les dons que les gens souhaitent
offrir la communauté et puis bah le
besoin de venir voir un peu ce qui se
passe à lévis en reprendre ses activités
mais ça représente aussi un soulagement
l'imaginent c'est important de de
repartir
c'est important d'être présent sur le
territoire et de pouvoir et bien se
connecter à un réseau emmaüs 1 qui
existe de manière importante en ile de
france sur la france entière aussi et il
manquait donc à trappes puisque ça
existait depuis longtemps donc cette
petite communauté aujourd'hui qui va
revivre
on va en parler juste dans un instant
alors si on revient en arrière pourquoi
les activités ont elles été stoppé
pendant un an et demi je pense qu'à
partir d'un moment du moment où les
choses ne peuvent plus bien fonctionné
se coordonner parmi les acteurs en place
quoi il y avait un problème de
gouvernance il y avait tout un ensemble
de choses
on fonctionne avec avec des bénévoles
ce n'est pas toujours très simple
association loi 1901 les gens doivent
montrer toute la bonne volonté avant la
disponibilité et il faut renouveler
aussi les ics les équipes abandonné
lorsque ce n'est pas possible eh bien
les choses peuvent s'arrêter comme
c'était le cas des locaux aussi qu'ils
étaient peut-être plus adapté
oui les locaux n'étaient pas adaptés
donc il a fallu prendre le temps
justement de tous
cette interruption pour retravailler un
projet en lien aussi avec emmaüs france
qui est beaucoup intervenu dans la
réflexion est aussi dans un soutien
économique à remonter ce projet comment
ça a été possible justement dhr la
rouverture il ya eu un rachat les locaux
notamment je crois alors on a racheté
les louent des locaux on a ensuite
effectué les travaux nécessaires à
l'amélioration de l'outil et puis et
puis voilà des choses se sont faites
tout simplement avec des bénévoles qui
se sont mobilisés durant ces deux ans
autour d'une réflexion et puis des
salariés dont je fais partie d'emmaüs
france qui ont importé
voilà la fois leur expérience et puis
aussi leur expertise
aujourd'hui c'est le corps est plus
fonctionnel du coup ces locaux sont très
fonctionnels oui c'est un très bel outil
de travail
cinquante cinq compagnons pardon sont
accueillis au sein de la communauté à
dans une maison à trappes ils vivent
dans une maison à traduire on vient
juste sur le principe de compagnons qui
est un principe fondateur pour emmaüs
rappelons que la première communauté
emmaüs en france a été créée par l'abbé
pierre en 1949 c'était la nuit plaisance
qu'est ce qu'un compagnon le compagnon
c'est une personne exclue qui n'a pas
trouvé sa place dans la société et qui
revient à maazou qui arrive à emmaüs en
été en capacité de travailler de
participer à l'ensemble des activités
proposées de vivre aussi en groupe et de
s'inscrire dans un projet global
voilà de solidarité également donc le
compagnon c'est une personne qui a vécu
différentes rupture aussi qui est en
marche donc de cette société je lui ai
dit et qu'il n'a pas pu travailler qui
n'a pas pu s'inscrire dans cette
dynamique là et surtout qui n'a pas
envie de montrer à quel point ils en
difficulté il a envie de prouver qu'il
est encore utile à cette société et donc
il vient participer avec emmaüs au
travail de récupération de valorisation
des objets puisqu'il vient chercher
finalement c'est se relancer dans cette
société
c'est se relance et se valoriser
retrouver de la dignité
donc ça c'est important qu'on puisse
s'inscrire dans un réseau aussi voilà au
même titre que les bénévoles quand ils
viennent là et c'est donc c'est se fond
dans cette société et comment va se
dérouler son passage au sein de la
communauté
alors
le compagnon est là autant de temps
qu'il le souhaite ça c'est clair on n'a
pas de durée limite sur la personne
travaille sur un projet et le redémarre
ou leur soit elle reste le temps qu'elle
le souhaite et travaillent avec nous sur
la communauté les compagnons participent
aux activités de récupération de
valorisation de tri de vente
voilà justement les dons sont
réceptionnés à partir de demain de
nouveaux attrape vous récupérez donc
c'est dont vous les remettez en est à
six est nécessaire mais plus voulait
revendre et qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu
est-ce qu on peut donner à emmaüs tout
vous regardez chez vous vous faites le
tour à 360 degrés vous regardez tout ce
qu'il vient ce sont des choses qui
peuvent nous arriver voilà tout
simplement que vous pouvez nous donner à
condition qu'elles soient en bon état
qu'elles soient réutilisables et bon
certaines choses même si elle ne
fonctionne pas comme l'électroménager
sont renvoyés sur des filières qui sont
après recyclé quoi et l'argent récolté
par ses bons ils vont servir à quoi
financer des actions sur le territoire
sur le local c'est une vraiment une
bonne question parce qu'on nous le
demande souvent donc l'argent sert
d'abord à à financer cette structure ce
que novice sans subventions on ne vit
que dans notre travail ça c'est une
volonté et même la philosophie des malus
des communautés emmaüs
ensuite on alimente aussi tout un réseau
de solidarité locale partir du nombre de
travailleurs sociaux nous sollicitent
pour meubler des familles pour soutenir
des familles en difficulté donc là on
intervient avec du mobilier ou tout
simplement financièrement on paye des
cotisations aussi à maïs france pour
alimenter le réseau national et les
difficultés qu'il y en as ionale voire
internationale aussi voilà donc cet
argent sert à tout ça dernière chose là
on reprend ses activités
emmaüs reprend ses activités à trappes
quels sont les premiers objectifs dans
les premiers mois de cette reprise
d'activité
alors d'abord se faire connaître faire
connaître la communauté pouvoir
justement accueillir le maximum de
personnes qui viennent visiter cette
communauté découvre aussi se découvrir
ce qu'est le mouvement emmaüs et puis un
objectif financier derrière il faut
pérenniser cette structure et développer
l'accueil d'autres compagnons
aujourd'hui qui sont à la rue qui nous
attendent
l'objectif c'est 10 à terme c'est ça
l'objectif c'est d'ailleurs et 20 une
communauté comme celle ci peut à terme
accueillir 20 compagnons mais dans un
premier temps on ira vers un autre
groupe de cinq prochainement jour je le
souhaite en tout cas merci franck le ton
d'avoir été avec nous responsable de la
communauté emmaüs attrapez-les reprend à
ses activités réception des dons à
nouveau à partir de demain ouverture de
la salle de vente prévue le 3 mars
emmaüs à trappes qui sera ouvert les
mercredis et samedis plus d'informations
sur le site internet de la communauté
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran on
restera poule enseignes lidl cherche à
s'implanter avenue des frères lumière
une arrivée est mal perçue par les
villes de trappes justement et aussi de
montigny le bretonneux
elles font front commun pour s'opposer à
l'installation du magasin le lieu choisi
est à proximité de zones commerciales
ouverture pourrait nuire au commerce de
proximité d'après les deux communes le
projet enfin ne serait pas conforme à la
réglementation selon trappe car situés
en zone d'activités des messages
romantiques et même des déclarations
d'amour les panneaux municipaux de
nombreuses communes était alors de la
saint-valentin aujourd'hui mercredi
reportage dans les rues yvelinoise à la
rencontre de ses anneaux de séez anonyme
et qui n hésitent pas à partager leur
bonheur un sujet michael et demi d'euros
et de wilfried richy
[Musique]
soyons les oies
son de bois d'arcy à elancourt elles
fleurissent malgré le froid de ce mois
de février les déclarations d'amour sur
les panneaux municipaux en ce 14 février
au petit matin david est venu s'assurer
que son mode où étaient bien inscrits
c'est la petite surprise de la
saint-valentin grâce à la mairie
d'elancourt donc c'est super original ça
permet vraiment de s'approprier la ville
et les panneaux qui sont souvent un peu
sans sans trop d'informations
personnalisées donc voilà bonne saint
valentin ma chérie une surprise
originale lancée l'an dernier dans cette
commune et qui rencontrent déjà un grand
succès nous avons eu 25 et donc pour toi
qui ont diffusé des messages déclarer
leur flamme alors amoureux ou alors
amoureuse et donc nous les publions
toute la journée sur les panneaux
électroniques et nous relayons aussi
l'information sur notre site internet
évidemment sur notre pompe facebook à sa
g instagram et twitter david a prévu de
revenir ce soir en famille pour
immortaliser ce moment
quant à ceux qui n'ont pas franchi le
cap rien ne les empêche de profiter de
cette vague d'amour et de prendre part à
ces instants de bonheur
autre déclaration d'amour ou pas les
sept départements franciliens ont envoyé
un gâteau en forme de coeur et emmanuel
macron sur ce président on peut lire
j'aime mon département message d'humour
au président de la république pour
défendre l'échelon départemental
hauts-de-seine seine-saint-denis et
val-de-marne sont pour rappel menacés de
suppression dans le cadre de la réforme
de la métropole du grand paris à
l'occasion de la saint-valentin encore
l'association prévention routière a
lancé une campagne digitale et mieux
vaut s'envoyer en l'air que sur la route
des messages de sensibilisation sont
diffusés est depuis lundi sur les
réseaux sociaux ils ont pour but
d'inciter les conducteurs à anticiper
leur retour de leur soirée en amoureux
les amoureux qui avait prévu de s'y
rendre aujourd'hui peut être déçu
d'ailleurs à cause de la météo le parc
de thoiry
elle n'a pas rouvert ce mercredi il
débutera sa saison a finalement ce
samedi le temps pour son nouveau
pensionnaire de s'acclimater le jeune
rhinocéros unesco qui est arrivé fin
janvier
reportage de camille lambert à peine
âgée de 3 ans unesco pèse déjà près de
deux tonnes arrivé le 25 janvier c'est
l'une de ses premières sorties avec ses
compagnons il découvre sa nouvelle
maison et ses voisins
son arrivée depuis le safari de peaugres
en ardèche est un symbole fort pour le
parc qui se remet doucement de la mort
de vince il y a un an
unesco et à thoiry pour grandir dans
quelques années ils pourraient aider à
préserver son espèce la mère de l'unesco
à gestantes et va mettre bas au mois de
mars
et donc il fallait que ce jeu de mal un
kit quitte son groupe d'origine
donc il va rester là quelques années si
le coordinateur du programme de
d'élevage des rhinocéros en europe a
besoin de lui en reproduction dans un
autre parc
effectivement il pourrait repartir dans
quelques années pour s'accoupler avec
une certaine semaine mais pas de
naissance de rhinau prévu à thoiry
unesco partage son box avec bruno un
mâle de cinq ans et grassi la doyenne de
37 ans les visiteurs pourront le
rencontrer dès le 17 février et
découvrir les autres nouveautés du parc
l'offre d'activités aérienne initiée
avec la tyrolienne du côté des lions a
été complété par un parcours dans les
arbres
on va évoluer dans des filets jusqu'à 9
mètres de hauteur avec une vue sur les
animaux de la plaine africaine
il ya eu dix semaines de montage dans
les arbres pour pouvoir accrocher ses
filets donc c'est vraiment une aventure
bondissante
on peut y aller à partir de 3 ans
accompagnés d'un adulte bien sûr le parc
de thoiry fête cette année ses 50 ans
pour l'occasion une nouvelle zone
d'immersion est en création
un trek australiens avec une volière
d'oiseaux exotiques et un parcours au
milieu des wallabies sera prêt pour le
printemps recensés et classer les plus
beaux arbres d'île de france les plus
rares et aussi les plus fragiles
ambitions du comité régional des arbres
remarquables une première réunion s'est
tenue hier à versailles bonsoir un cabri
tout ça
vous êtes là membres de ce comité comme
comité pardon va y arriver
membre de ce comité vous est également
la présidente de l' agence à des espaces
verts d'ile-de-france conseillère
régionale également délégué spécial à
l'agriculture et la ruralité j'ajoute
que vous êtes également la mère d'orson
ville alors avant de parler de ce comité
de ces missions est également de ses
prochaines actions il convient de
présenter ce qu'est un arbre remarquable
écouter la définition d'alain baraton
jardinier-en-chef du grand parc du
château de versailles c'est au micro
demi
les 1000 euros et de patrick jacques de
dixmude un arbre remarquable est un
arbre qui doit être protégé pour son
histoire sa beauté son emplacement
les légendes qu'il peut porter en lui en
un mot c'est à naples qui ne doit pas
être coupé pour n'importe quel prétexte
d'où l'idée de yann wehrling et de la
région de les recenser de les protéger
pour que nos enfants puissent eux aussi
profiter des arbres remarquables des
arbres peuvent parfaitement être
remarquable tout en ayant une espérance
de vie beaucoup plus récentes
prenez l'exemple d'oradour-sur-glane
lorsque vous arrivez dans ce lieu dédié
j'allais dire eh bien malheureusement
martyrs de la gare de la dernière guerre
un chêne vous accueille ce chêne n'est
pas très vieux
il est pourtant témoin de la barbarie
nazie et l'a donc à ce titre le label
j'allais dire remarquable lorsque vous
plantez aujourd'hui un arbre en
commémorant les attentats de paris ces
tables devient de fait remarquable donc
l'arbre remarquable peut-être jeune âge
et beau moins beau mais c'est à l'ap qui
doit garder qui doivent me justifier
toute notre attention toute notre
protection et tout notre amour oral
cabré on l'entendait dans cette
interview à l'arbre au même titre qu'un
monument
c'est un témoin de l'histoire oui
l'arbre est un témoin de l'histoire il
faut pas oublier que l'arbre est un être
vivant
donc c'était important qu'on classe au
niveau de la région ile-de-france est un
souhait de la présidente valérie
pécresse de pouvoir identifier ces
arbres remarquables sur l'île de france
des arbres de toute beauté notamment
dans les yvelines je pense notamment un
sophora dans le petit trianon qui a été
planté sous louis xiv il ya aussi un
platane à versailles qui était planté
pendant la révolution française
oui c'est une histoire comme ça quand
les gens se promènent se rendent compte
que l'art pour peut être très âgé et
amène son histoire amène son ce que
disait alain baraton hier dans le comité
c'est qu'au delà de l'arbre remarquable
c'est subjectif parce qu'on
on va trouver que ce terme est
remarquable parce que on a une histoire
basket c'est ta paix sinon c'est vrai
souvent c'est un rappel à l'histoire
alors première réunion de ce comité
régional des arbres remarquables hier il
est présidée par yann wehrling le prêt
si c'était au parc du château de
versailles tout en symboles finalement
de commencer au parc du château de
versailles
ben oui c'est un symbole de commencer
dans ce lieu mythique du parc de
versailles avec toute l'histoire et tout
la protection qu'ils font dont alain
baraton gère sur le parc de versailles
et tous ces arbres donc c'était une
volonté de commencer dans un endroit
mythique et en plus dans un endroit
discipline donc ça nous tenait à coeur
donc ce comité régional lancé quels sont
les objectifs alors les objectifs la
mission qui a été confiée à yann
wehrling était de faire un inventaire
d'un inventaire de tous les arbres
remarquables en ile de france et donc de
se servir de ce qui existe déjà donc
hier au comité de pilotage il y avait
des associations qui ont déjà fait un
travail avec le sérieux de la seine et
marne
il y avait également l'office national
des forêts qui ont déjà travaillé depuis
20 ans pour certains donc on va
travailler surtout cet inventaire afin
de classifier de classifier et à terme
de pouvoir permettre aux franciliens
quand il se promène dans une forêt dans
un pas d'identifier un arm et remettre
comme je dis souvent remettre l'arbre au
coeur de la forêt parce que on ne
connaît plus nos forêts et j'espère que
l'identification de ces arbres
remarquables permettra aux franciliens
mais de d'adopter de se réadapter à la
forêt francilienne donc évidemment
ailleurs cette première ligne qui fait
exister a esquissé une heure mais bon
c'est un échange qui s'est fait entre
tout le monde comme tous les membres
pour savoir comment eux caractérisé quel
est le caractère sur le l'arbre
remarquable à pour certains comme alain
baraton
c'était le côté historique pour d'autres
c'était le coup de coeur pour d'autres
c'était là la dimension de labre donc
voila c'était en échange et ça nous a
permis de
de voir plusieurs idées et le but
maintenant c'est de travailler et de
lancer la deuxième étape de ce comité
qui sera un peu de lancer les grandes
lignes et de savoir qu'est ce qu'on va
comment la définir cet arbre remarquable
si on regarde la composition de ce
comité il ya des experts publics il ya
également des associatifs donc on y
ajoute alain baraton on en discutait le
jardinier en chef du parc du château de
versailles
c'est une force qu'il ya une diversité
finalement d'interlocuteurs oui c'est
une force parce que chacun avec leur
sensibilité leur leur vécu de permettre
d'avoir il ya l'association arbre qui
est au niveau national reconnu où ils
ont labellisé depuis 20 ans je crois
c'est 500 arbres donc c'est sur 20 ans
c'est pas énorme mais ils ont une
connaissance lors l'office national des
forêts bien évidemment connais très bien
depuis colbert les forêts franciliennes
et dans nos forêts en ile de france qui
sont des forêts royales il faut pas
l'oublier donc souvent quand vous
promener en forêt par exemple 2
de rambouillet vous remarquez à un
croisement il ya un arbre s'était voulu
à l'époque par le roi donc on se promène
on a cette histoire là donc c'est on a
des experts autour de la table qui nous
amènent leur technicité et leur et leur
vécu on rappelle que ce comité a été
lancé dans le cadre aussi du plan vert
de la région ile-de-france pourquoi
c'est important pour la région de
protéger ces arbres ah oui c'est
important
la présidente valérie pecresse pendant
sa campagne s'est vraiment rendu compte
que on ne connaissait pas notre fort et
nos arbres donc le plan vert sert
végétalisée l'ile-de-france 500 hector
500 hectares d'ici 2021 qui saigne 2021
et donc elle se sert bien sûr de lagence
des espaces verts qui est le bras armé
de la région surtout ce qui est fort et
parce qu'on gère dix mille hectares de
forêt en ile de france
donc c'était important parce que comme
je vous disais tout à l'heure il faut
que les franciliens puissent revenir en
forêt en zone périurbaine comme en zone
rurale et par cette identification ce
label parce qu'à terme ça serait de
essayer de labelliser et que
l'ile-de-france ce soit vraiment la
première région qui lance ce label est
également ce que souhaiterait la
présidente de région valérie pécresse
c'est qu'on ait un statut de l'arbre
statut de l'awb équivalent également
sites classés ou un site classé et
protégé l'attention la protection de
l'art ne veut pas dire non plus qu'on
n'a pas une vision économique sur la
forêt parce que c'est ce que je disais
hier dans le comité
il faut pas mettre notre forêt sous
cloche il faut l'exploiter mais il faut
qu'elle soit remarquable sur certains
arbres mais également de l'exploiter
donc il ya vraiment une limite très
fragile il nous reste moins d'une minute
dernière chose sur le calendrier là pour
se connecter d'autres réunions prévues
dans les brochures le mois de mai juin
on va se réunir pour rediscuter suis
vraiment sur le label et les critères
merci à un cabri d'avoir été avec nous
membres du comité régional des arbres
remarquables présidente de l' agence des
espaces verts va d'île de france et pour
en savoir plus sur les arbres
remarquables je vous invite vous parliez
tout à l'heure à vous rendre sur le site
de l'association arbre qui travaille
depuis plusieurs années sur 7 sur 7
thématiques culture pour refermer ce
journal benjamin flao est qualifié comme
l'un à des dessinateurs les plus
talentueux de sa génération il dessine
depuis l'enfance
son oncle dit de lui est d'ailleurs
qu'il est un homme crillon l'artiste
expose actuellement à l'espace est
philippe noiret aux clayes-sous-bois
rencontre avec mélanie poquet et nicolas
landry naim en feu l'un et gunther
marins hollandais les deux personnages
principaux de benjamin flao l'artiste
fait de la bande dessinée inspirée de
souvenirs de voyage c'est un livre que
que j'ai fait à partir de 1 voyage que
j'avais fait mais plusieurs voyages que
j'avais fait en afrique de l'est qui au
départ était sous forme de jeu le
matériau que j'avais c'était
c'était plutôt des carnets de voyage des
carnets
dessin et puis des petites notes et que
j'ai transformée en
que j'ai transformée en
récit en fiction et finalement ça a
donné un diptyque avec tous les
ingrédients que j'ai pu piocher pour ces
voyageurs
[Musique]
l'afrique est la mer pour ce nantais de
naissance le grand bleu est une source
d'inspiration
ce café
frappant danser dans ces pays d'afrique
c'est que il ya des choses qui sont
restés immuables
en tout cas des choses qui existaient
encore chez nous il ya cent ans et qui
ont disparu qui ont qu'on retrouve dans
les musées et chez eux c'est encore bien
vivant on s'est pas vraiment c'est pas
vraiment un garage s'est pas vraiment il
ya un peu de bazar
il ya des choses qu'on voit pas trop
bien voilà mes rêves sont un peu fait de
tout ça benjamin flao dessine depuis
l'enfance aux histoires vraies se mêlent
les rêves et une vie à double facette
moi j'ai un peu d'eau de deux vies
stallergènes vie qui se passe à
l'extérieur où par exemple kim kim
on fait voyager qui me permet d'aller
promener donc en afrique par exemple
puis une vie intérieure qui par exemple
au maire rêve
alors là je parle de l'aspect graphique
surtout parce qu'il s'agit de l'expo de
dessin
voyageur au long cours les placards de
ses dessins sur des murs le temps d'une
exposition
avant de repartir vers de nouveaux rêves
c'est la fin de ce journal un rappel
avant de se quitter dès ce soir 22h en
répercussion d'un mouvement social local
un train a sur deux est prévu sur les
lignes c n et u est les perturbations
sont à prévoir jusqu'à vendredi 8h du
matin vous pouvez rester informé sur le
site transilien.com cette édition vous
pouvez la revoir bien sûr sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]